افادت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه في بيان
نشرته على منصه اكس بان الحوثيين في اليمن
نفذوا هجومين على سفينتين تجاريتين في
جنوب البحر الاحمر امس الاثنين واوضح
البيان ان ناقله النفط سوان اتلانتك تعرضت
لضربه بطائره مسيره وصاروخ بالستي مضاد
للسفن بينما ابلغت سفينه البضائع كلارا عن
انفجار قرب موقعها في جنوب البحر الاحمر
وقالت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه انه لم
ترد تقارير بشان اصابات في اي من الحادثين
في جنوب
البحر وكان الناطق العسكري باسم انصار
الله الحوثيين يحيى سريع قد اعلن في وقت
سابق ان قواتهم نفذت عمليه عسكريه نوعيه
ضد سفينتين لهما ارتباط بالكيان الصهيوني
الاولى سفينه سوان اتلانتك وهي محمله
بالنفط والاخرى سفينه ام اس سي كلارا
وتحمل حاويات وقد تم الاستهداف بطائرتين
بحريتين واضاف سريع في حسابه على منصه اكس
ان جماعته تطمئن كل السفن المتجهه الى
كافه موانئ العالم عدا الموانئ
الاسرائيليه بانه لن يصيبها اي ضرر وان
عليها الابقاء على جهاز التعارف مفتوحا
كما اكد استمرار الجماعه في منع جميع
السفن المتجهه الى الموانئ الاسرائيليه
ايا كانت جنسيتها من الملاحه في بحر العرب
والبحر الاحمر حتى ادخال ما يحتاجه الصامت
في قطاع غزه من غذاء
ودواء